[MUSIC PLAYING]
BABI SEAL: So consider for a
second the value of search,
how timely and relevant
responses bring value
to your life.
Then consider other
Google properties--
Mail, Gmail, Chrome,
YouTube, Android, and Play.
Next consider that
Google delivers
these services on a
daily basis to a billion
of our fellow users.
And underpinning
these services are
a set of key innovations and
infrastructure that drive them.
Our goal at Google Cloud is
to share these innovations
and infrastructure with you
so that you can create value
and delight your customers.
I'm Babi.
And I'm joined by
my colleague Oz.
And today we would
like to talk to you
about a critical piece of this
infrastructure, that Google
Global Network.
More specifically, we'd like
to talk to you about Andromeda.
Andromeda is a network
virtualization platform
for Google Cloud.
We'd like to show you
how you can use Andromeda
to deliver network
services that are
fast, reliable, and at scale.
Before we get started, we'd like
to acknowledge the work done
by the Andromeda team.
More specifically,
this presentation
is based on their paper that
they presented at the USENIX
conference for NSDI.
It's really a privilege for
us to be in front of you
and to share the work done by
this great team of engineers
and many unsung heroes
that work tirelessly
in terms for delivering
these network services day in
and day out.
How many of you have seen this
network, this slide by now?
Right?
But it bears worth
repeating, right?
We've got 100,000 miles
of fiber, both terrestrial
as well as submarine.
It's extremely well
provisioned, 20 regions,
around 125-plus
points of presence,
or more than 52
interconnect points,
all which gives you
connectivity close to where
you are, connectivity close
to where your customers are.
And you can get
high availability
because you can multi-home
to any of these two
regions or three
regions and get pretty
significant availability.
Moreover, we've designed
this network from the day
up for performance
and scalability.
So we control the point where
you on board on this network.
We control the network
and the data centers.
So at the end of
the day, you end up
with a very compelling
user experience.
And we are building
this out even more
and investing in
bringing it out.
So I refer to as
innovations in networking.
The first thing I'd like
you to note, and contrary
to popular belief,
is that we are still
innovating in networking.
You might have heard Amin
Vahdat talk about some
of these innovations.
What's interesting
that he describes
is that a lot of these
innovations in networking
were actually driven by the
innovations in distributed
services that were
powering those services
with a billion plus users.
And he said that those
distributed systems required
such significant
bandwidth that we just
could not buy a network
that was enough to meet
our requirements.
So we had to go and build it.
And so these are some
of the innovations
as a result of that.
I'll cover some of them
in the next slides.
But I'd like you
to take a moment
and notice some of the key
commonalities underpinning
many of them.
Yes, it is software-defined
networking.
The basic idea between
software-defined networking
is that you have a centralized
control plane that provisions
and controls the networking
elements for providing
connectivity from end to
end and enforces policy.
You see, a lot of those big
problems become tractable
when you have a logical
centralized brain that
takes actually control
away from the networking
elements, provisions them,
and again, enforces policy.
Our Andromeda is also based on
a software-defined networking
architecture.
So what does a Google
network look like?
Right, the innovations
that I was referring to
are Data Center
Network, Jupiter.
It's actually a 40-gig data
center Clos-based fabric.
It's also SDN based.
We have over a
petabit per second
of total bisectional bandwidth.
Connecting this
data center fabrics
are our WAN Network, the B4.
It, too, is an SDN network.
And it, too, has
extremely high throughput
of the order of terabits.
B2 connects our Google
to the backbone.
Its protected with
very high SLAs.
And what we do is we
try to carry traffic
as much over our
well-provisioned backbone
and well-provisioned network
before handing it off
to the internet so
that your experience
is as optimal as possible.
Espresso is our SDN
to the peering edge.
What it does is it actually,
with the advantage of SDN,
dynamically chooses from where
we serve our customers based
on end-to-end measurements.
So it's not always the
most proximate exit point.
But because of SDN,
we are able to choose
what's the most optimal in
terms of user experience based
on availability and latency.
So this is what our
Google network looks like.
So if you were to
take and come and have
a piece of Google Cloud, what
would some of your requirements
be?
Some extremely basic?
Of course, you
need multi-tenancy.
You need functional as well
as performance isolation.
You need it to be
highly available.
You need elastic
network services
that help you load
balance, protect
using firewalls
and ACLs, connect
to your on-prem, and
of course, monitor.
You need us to be agile
in our feature delivery
and iterate, and improve,
and scale, and deliver
these services to you.
Last but not the least, and
a key portion of this talk,
is that you we have
to make it scalable.
So how do we get there?
Before I dive into this
question, let me ask you,
what thoughts come to
your mind when I mention
VPC, Virtual Private Cloud?
Anyone?
Because you see, VPC has
different connotations
in different contexts.
At Google, VPCs are global.
It's a global model.
It's not isolated.
You don't have regional
replication of configuration
and connectivity.
It's also shareable.
You can have one
policy globally,
but you can also have the
advantage of fine-grained IAM
rules.
And of course, on
the VPC, we give you
access to Google's
differentiated services.
I'm going to talk about
Andromeda in the next section.
But essentially, we
help you get that,
to get these network
services, by running
your global VPC on Andromeda.
So like I had
mentioned, Andromeda
is our network virtualization
for Google Cloud.
What do I mean by
network virtualization?
It essentially refers to having
multiple virtual networks that
essentially run on top of
a shared physical network.
On a virtual network, you
can have multiple VMs that
essentially talk to each other.
And these physical VMs in turn
run on a physical network.
The IP addressing scheme
of a virtual network
is totally decoupled
from a virtual network.
Forwarding in virtual networks
is done by means of a vSwitch.
A vSwitch essentially has a
mapping of the destination VM
address to the actual
physical host's IP address.
Packet forwarding
happens essentially
like it does with all network
overlays, using encapsulation.
You encapsulate the
customer's IP packet
into another IP packet
with the transport header
meant for the destination
IP address of the host.
So now this is where
the fun stuff comes.
What does Andromeda
architecture look like?
The Andromeda
architecture is based
on a hierarchy of control
planes and data planes.
At the top of the
control plane hierarchy
are our virtual
machine controllers.
These virtual
machine controllers
receive an abstract
representation of the network,
specifying what are your QS
rules, what are your firewall
rules, what are your routes,
what are your subnets, what
are the VMS, et cetera.
It then translates that
into open flow commands
to the virtual switches
you see in the grade below.
It does not directly communicate
with the virtual switches.
But it goes through a proxy
called the open flow front end.
These open flow front
ends serve two purposes.
One, it serves to decouple
the open flow protocol
from the Andromeda
control plane.
It also has no state.
It essentially just translates
the open flow config commands
into open flow
protocol commands.
Because it has no
state, it serves
as a static connection point for
the vSwitches to the network.
Because of that,
you can potentially
upgrade the control plane
without affecting the vSwitches
below.
The vSwitches have
a control plane
based on the standards-based
open flow vSwitch.
But we've added
proprietary extensions
for delivering some of
our network services.
Now a key takeaway
from this slide
is that our VMC controllers
are sharded, are partitioned.
And that helps you get
scalability, right?
If you want to bring
a new rack online,
all you have to do is spin up
a new job for a virtual machine
controller, some open flow
front ends, and voila,
you're up and running.
Each instance of a VMC
is also replicated.
There are three instances,
one master, two standby,
using the Paxos protocol.
So having it sharded, I
mean having it replicated
gives you high availability.
So our whole control
plane is highly available
and does scale out.
Now moving on to
our data plane--
if there's one thing I'd like
you to take away of our data
plane, or what's unique
about our data plane,
is that it is a very performant
OS-bypassed user space
architecture running on
a dedicated CPU core.
When I say fast, even though
it's running on user space,
we can hit about 3 million
packets per second.
It's crafted very optimally,
but taking advantage of things
like memory locality avoiding,
synchronization like locks,
and taking advantage
of large page sizes,
and avoiding thread hand-offs,
and avoiding system calls,
doing end-to-end batching,
all to make it extremely fast.
Now it's also extremely secure.
Remember, this is a process
running in user space.
There is no root access.
In addition, the code is so
constrained that its attack
surface is also very limited.
We also implement the
best-of-breed security
practices, such as address-based
[INAUDIBLE] randomization
and having stack canaries,
alter events, stack overflow.
So net-net, it's an
extremely secure process.
One point I should
mention is let's contrast
this implementation of the data
plane with other alternatives.
One thing you could
do with a data plane
is implement it in a kernel.
Or you could implement
it in hardware.
The challenges with
those are, if you
have a crash in the
data plane and a kernel,
you take the whole system out.
And, you know, god help you if
you have it in the hardware.
Last but not the least,
it's also robust.
When a process-- it's
a user space process,
so you can restart it.
The control plane just
detects that the user
space has crashed, and you
can restart it very easily.
In addition, we have
mechanisms by which
you can upgrade, do a hitless
upgrade of the data plane
process.
So net-net, we can effectively
roll out a data plane change
every week, be agile, and have
many rapid releases on the data
plane.
So with this control
and unique data plane,
What are some of the network
services enabled by Andromeda?
You, of course, mentioned
isolation as your requirement.
We'll see some of these
services and how Andromeda
enables some of these services.
But two key takeaways
are, we make
them very highly available,
and there is no chokepoint.
It's an architecture that
scales out very well.
So diving right in, how do
you get functional isolation?
Functional isolation, it's
a standard overlay model,
where you encapsulate
your customer IP
packet and the other
outer IP packet,
and essentially get
functional isolation that way.
Performance
isolation-- you know,
when I mentioned that the
data planes were hierarchical?
The control and data
planes were hierarchical.
Even the data plane
has the falling paths.
We have the fastpath.
This is for your
performance-critical path.
It has fixed cycle budget.
And there is isolation
by TX and RX for that.
In addition, there are
certain networking features
that are obviously
CPU-intensive that
will take more than
necessary cycles than usual.
For those we have the
CPU-intensive path.
And the way we implement
them are per VM threads,
CPU attributed to
the VM container
for those more
CPU-intensive operations.
This essentially allows us
to be more fair because it's
a poor VM thread with attributes
for that fairly allocated
for that container.
In addition, having
the CPU-intensive path
helps us to decouple the feature
velocity from the fastpath.
So typically you are not
modifying the fastpath when
you want to add new features.
You typically add
new features that
are more performance intensive
with the per VM thread, so you
maintain both feature velocity
as well as not disrupt
the core fastpath functionality.
There's also something
called Hoverboard.
I'll discuss this a little
further down the road.
But it's essentially a
dedicated software gateway
for processing the
long tail flows.
Now before I-- I kind
of gave the answer away,
but essentially, how many of
you remember the Spectre bug?
Right?
Mindmeld?
So if you remember,
when we hit that bug,
we were able to upgrade
our infrastructure
and just let you guys,
our customers, our users,
know that we had upgraded,
that there was an issue,
we had upgraded it.
And the way we were
able to upgrade
the infrastructure
without disruption
was by using live migration.
What is live migration?
It is, which is
essentially migrate
one VM to another machine with
extremely minimal blackout
period.
Where does Andromeda
come into the play?
Andromeda facilitates
live migration,
even across clusters.
If you step back a
little bit, right?
If you think of a global routing
plane, and routing converges,
enabling us to do--
in the time it takes
for routing to converge,
the time we're able to do this
VM migration across clusters.
It's pretty impressive.
And like I said, it's useful
for maintenance upgrades,
optimizing the placement
of VMs, and of course,
fixing the zero-day
bugs under the cover.
The way Andromeda
does this is it
essentially directs the
migration source host
switch to help in all
traffic that it receives
from other gateways and
hosts to the target switch
during the blackout period.
After the blackout
period ends, it then
instructs all other
VMs and our gateways
to then send traffic
to the target switch.
I mean, this is a very
useful feature for us,
maintaining high
availability and resiliency.
Now going on to the
network services
that I was referring to--
internal load balancing,
it essentially
helps you scale and
grow your services
behind a virtual load
balancing IP address that
are only accessible from
the back end instances.
You know, inside
the Google network,
inside your customer
network, it's all--
I mean, it's mostly
RFC 1918 addresses.
So you use an RFC 1918
VIP for this purpose.
We support health checks, and
we preserve the client IP.
What's important to note is
that internal load balancing
has no middle proxy.
There is nothing called an
actual internal load balancer.
So traditionally you had a VIP.
You had an actual proxy instance
that did the load balancing
to your back ends.
But the way GCP does this
internal load balancing,
is that the load balancing
functionality is directly
embedded and programmed
in the client VM itself.
So the load balancing
decision happens
in the client VM itself.
And it then gets sent to
the appropriate back end.
What this means is that we can
scale out our load balancer
without having any chokepoints.
The way it works is essentially
the controllers program
the open flow rules
into the client VMs.
It associates the back
end VMs with the VIP.
The open flow, there are
certain proprietary extensions
in terms of doing sticky load
balancing, because you have
to do both connection tracking
as well as doing consistent
hashing to essentially get the
load balancing function that
is both scalable, fair, and
also resilient to outages.
We support health checks that
track the state of the back end
instances.
And this is essentially what
the control plane for an ILB
looks like.
Now you have to connect on prem.
Typically you use
either a physical router
that has both support for
BGP and VPN functionality.
And the BGP portion
of that gateway
learns your on-prem routes.
And then the data
plane of that gateway
encrypts it using IPsec,
VPN, and then sends it
across the tunnel.
We took a slightly
different approach.
We could have, of course,
just deployed this instance.
But in order to make
your router both scale
and make it highly available, we
actually took the routing piece
and made it a separate job.
A lot of our implementations
are essentially just,
you can think of it as
jobs running in our fabric.
This cloud router job
peers with the BGP on prem,
learns her routes,
and then it programs
those routes to the
VM, telling them
that in order to reach
your customer data center,
send the packets
directly to the VM.
So what does this buy you?
You essentially get a separation
of the control and data plane.
Hence, you get more resiliency.
When I talk about high
availability, what
this translates to
is that you have,
essentially, VPN
jobs or router jobs
that are available in a pool.
When we have a command to
create a VPN or create a router,
the Config Manager
essentially instructs,
let's say for our router,
the routing manager
to allocate a router from
this pool of router tasks
and assigns them to that job.
The routing manager then
talks to the fabric manager
and the Andromeda control plane,
setting up the associations
between the router and the VMs.
Now should a router
process crash,
it's fine because the data plane
continues to forward packets
as before till
the BGP hold time.
The routing manager, which is
tracking the routing instance,
detects that the current
router has gone away,
spins up a new routing instance,
and essentially re-establishes
a relationship.
So you have high
availability and no downtime,
even if the control plane
of the router crashes.
Similar fashion,
think of firewalls.
Typically, firewalls have been
deployed at the perimeter.
There are potentially
chokepoints.
And they didn't scale very well.
With Andromeda architecture,
our firewall rules
are actually deployed directly
on our compute engines,
the ingress and the egress.
There is connection tracking.
And that's the way
we are able to scale,
because there is no chokepoint.
All the firewall rules
are deployed directly
on the compute engines per se.
So to summarize, there
is no chokepoint,
it's stateful with
connection tracking.
And we also support
flexible grouping mechanisms
for tags and service accounts.
So now we have seen
services such as firewalls,
load balancers, and routers
being deployed using Andromeda.
I'm going to segue
into a new topic,
but that's very relevant.
How do you scale with Andromeda?
Remember when I had
made a reference
to it being a global network?
Well global networks are big.
You also have to remember
that a lot of our users
are Fortune 100 clients and a
lot of large internet companies
with very large
internet-based workloads.
So there are asks for a
network having 100K-plus VMs
in addition to
having more networks.
Another point to note
is that it's not just
the size of the network
or the number of networks.
There's also the
concern of how do you
provision a large network
really, really fast?
So if you take of use
cases, such as MapReduce
our TensorFlow, there is a need
to provision a really large
network really, really fast.
How do you do that?
So the way we do that is
with using Hoverboards.
Hoverboards are, in
essence, a software gateway.
If you come from
the routing world,
think of it as a top
of rack [INAUDIBLE]..
I mean, think of it as a
route reflector, a BGP route
reflector.
If you come from
the switching world,
think of it as a top of rack
switch, which is essentially
forwarding information
for all the flows.
Of course, it's a dedicated
software instance.
You can have larger
forwarding tables.
The virtual switches
themselves have essentially--
you know, they're a default--
the Hoverboard's
a default gateway.
Default routes from the
virtual switch itself
to the Hoverboard,
very standard.
So with this way, you can
scale your control pane.
The reason programming time is
not significant, because see,
all your programming is a small
subset of Hoverboard as opposed
to programming every switch.
As you can see, the
order of difference
in terms of programming time.
Last but not the least, it's
important to note that this,
if you're getting control
plane scalability,
there's a trade-off
in data plane
scalability because
you are having
to provision your data plane to
deal with the peak bandwidth.
You have to provision
the Hoverboard
to deal with that peak
bandwidth of all the flows.
So how do we get
around that requirement
for supporting the peak
bandwidth of all the flows
that has to go through
the Hoverboard?
Well, the way they do
it is we essentially
offload some
high-bandwidth flows
to the virtual switches
directly, right?
So we essentially program.
We detect that a flow
is very high bandwidth.
And we program it directly
to go from the virtual switch
to the virtual switch itself
and offload the Hoverboard.
In this way, we get both control
plane scalability as well as
data plane scalability.
But how does this work, really?
Why does it work?
We went and studied
all the network flows
in our data center, all
the east-west flows.
And we noticed is that
most VM pairs don't really
talk to each other.
And very few, if they
do talk to each other,
have very low
bandwidth requirements.
It's only an
extremely small amount
that has really high
bandwidth flows amongst them.
So those are the ones we
offload from the Hoverboard
to the vSwitches
themselves, right?
Now going back to just this
point about why does it take--
is it quicker to provision
the Hoverboards, right?
Because you have only a
small subset of the software
switches that you
have to provision.
So the programming time
is nice and linear.
But think about preprogramming
all the virtual switches
with all the forwarding rules.
It essentially starts
out as a quadratic growth
in terms of programming time.
But slowly, if you are in a
specific zone and a lot of VMs
share the same physical
host, the programming time
then becomes linear.
But it's too late.
I mean, you've already
exceeded the programming time
with the quadratic growth.
So effectively,
with Hoverboards,
we are able to see a 37%
improvement in programming
time for large networks.
We've started implementing
routing features
on the Hoverboard.
Additional features,
such as load balancing
and other firewall features
are in progress of development.
Now I'm going to
hand it over to Oz,
who's going to show you
a real ILB in action.
OSVALDO COSTA: In this demo
here that we have prepared,
the idea is to show you guys
a real use case with some
of the features that
Babi was covering
and delivered using Andromeda.
So we have an automated
deployment with multiple VPC
networks, as you
guys can see here,
so three VPC networks--
one called DMZ, another one
Prod, another one Dev.
Those VPCs are being connected
by multi-NIC Linux firewalls.
And in those VPC, there are
also internal load balancers
attached to managed instance
groups doing auto-scaling.
So with this demo here,
what we are going to show
is the auto-scaler in
action, showing the ILB
with the preserved client
IP that Babi mentioned.
So there is no
proxy in the middle.
So connections from the clients
go directly to the servers.
We are also going to show the
service discovery, the DNS
name, for the ILB,
which is a new feature,
and how to monitor all of
that with the Stackdriver.
So here in the beginning--
let me just increase this here.
So what we are going
to show is first
the network being defined,
so the three networks
that I mentioned, Dev, Prod,
and DMZ with different segments.
Now defining the fire rules,
we try to find at the VPC level
but enforce at the
instance level.
So one of the rules, the last
one, are the health checks.
The are required for the ILB.
And next the instances
that we have--
so we have the bastion that we
are going to use for access,
the load test VMs to generate
traffic, and a single web
server in this first
step, just to show
you guys the performance that we
are going to generate and blast
that VM.
And so just to show
you here, there
are two MIGs, both of them
with auto-scaling off.
And the web server MIG, there
is just a single instance,
auto-scaling off, so a single--
it's not going to auto-scale.
Next what we are
going to show here
is a start providing
access, just
to show that this is
a live environment.
So the real IP, for example,
for this first Linux firewall
is getting through the
GCLB and then going
to the Linux firewall.
So this is the
nice landing page.
One thing that I just wanted
to highlight, it's doing nat.
So that's why you can you
do not see the XFF there,
but you do see the
real client IP.
Now there is a GCLB configured
to deliver this service as
well.
So the GCLB, the
external IP that
is providing the load
balancing across the firewalls,
if we hit it, you guys will
see a difference, which
is the X-Forwarded-For Header.
Because the GCLB is a
proxy-based service.
So that's the main
difference, just
to show you guys that
both services are--
the services are available
through both, the GCLB
and the direct connected IP.
Now we are going to connect
here to the bastion host
and start basically two
connections, one to the web
server, and another
one to the load test.
So we can generate
traffic and show you what
a single instance can deliver.
One important
thing also to note,
and I'll highlight
here during the demo,
is I have two web
servers loaded.
So one of them is
showing, responding
to port 80, which
is the one that you
saw there, which is a very,
very small page, so low request.
And the other one is 8080,
which is running a high process.
So here, I'm just
showing a command just
to show you guys that
this VM is programmed
to respond to packets destined
to the ILB, which is the 10 0 1
10, as you guys can see there.
So that's how we can show
that the IP, the packets, they
are delivered to the server.
They reach directly the server.
They do not flow through
any middle layer.
Now we are going to show here
the servers that I mentioned.
So there are two
servers, one listening
on 8080, another one on 80.
On 80 it's that simple
landing page that I showed.
And on 8080, it's
actually a fractal.
I started here a CPU
utilization monitor.
As you can see, there are
pretty much no utilization.
And I'll generate some traffic.
Since this web server
is running a fractal,
so there is a lot
of CPU utilization.
So I'll generate two
sessions actually,
which is here the command.
So it will be 20 sessions
with a rate of two per second.
And so we can see that the
CPU is spiking close to 85%.
And again, this is using a
very CPU-intensive server.
So once we do that, we are going
now back to the MIG to show--
to change the config
of the MIG so we
can show the auto-scaling.
And just before that, if
I issue here the command
with the watch, so we can take
a look at the open connections
and generate the
sessions again, then
we are going to see that
the commands, targeting now
the ILB.
So the first is starting the
real IP, so the IP from 0.5
targeting the dot six.
The next one that is
going to be done here
is generating traffic
targeting the ILB
address, which is this DNS
here being highlighted.
So that's the DNS
entry that was created,
that was defined when
creating the ILB.
So sending packets
to that ILB, then we
can see that,
actually, the packet
monitor that will be done
here in the [INAUDIBLE]..
So first a curl, just to
make sure that that ILB
is responding to the traffic.
And now when I start
generating that traffic,
then we'll be able to see
in the connection tracking
that the target IP is 10
0 1 10, which is the ILB.
So that VM, once it's part of
a managed instance group tied
to the internal
load balancing, is
programmed to respond to packets
destined directly to the ILB.
And one thing to highlight here
is that the number of sessions,
which was around 2,000
connections per second,
was the same number either
targeting directly the web
server or targeting the ILB.
So there is no
chokepoint in the middle.
So now we are going to
configure the instance group
and increase the
max size, actually
enable the auto-scaler.
So we go to the MIG, Edit,
the Managing Sys Group,
enable auto-scaling, and set the
target CPU utilization to 80%,
increase the number
of instances to six,
and reduce the cool down.
So cool down period is
the number of seconds
before the instance is seen
as ready to receive traffic.
So we're going to
have to change that
just so it improves our demo.
But in real life, you
should monitor that
and see the amount
of time that you
need before your instance
is ready to receive traffic.
Now I have started
the CPU utilization,
just to show here that
it was changed already.
So it's ready to
receive traffic.
And if you take a look at the
monitoring in the console,
we can see that there
is one instance.
And the total CPU
usage will be available
as-- it will take a
few seconds, but will
be available as 80%, which is
the threshold that we have set.
Once I start generating
the traffic, which is here,
so 1,200 sessions with a
rate of four per second, then
I'll blast the CPU
for this machine.
And we'll have to wait a little
bit until the MIG kicks in.
So now switching
to Stackdriver, I
have created this
custom dashboard that
will show the per VM CPU
utilization plus all the ILB
statistics, so we can monitor.
But also, if we go here
directly to the instances,
we can see a list
of all the instances
that's going to load here
with the CPU utilization.
Now we are seeing just
one, because of course, it
takes few seconds
until the MIG kicks in,
the new instances are created,
and the CPU is loaded.
We can also see
this new feature.
I don't know if
you guys are aware.
But in Stackdriver, we
have loaded several metrics
and available already in
Stackdriver for the ILB.
So we can see all
the throughput,
the packets, inbound,
outbound, latency
for doing a breakdown by
instance group, for example,
by server, or showing
all the key metrics here.
So it's everything available
already in Stackdriver.
This is built in.
There is nothing that needs
to be customized to see this.
And then you can break down
by several parameters here,
several options, and
then take a look at it.
Similarly, just to
show you guys here,
we also have metrics
available for GCLB.
It's not the focus
of this presentation.
We have others specifically
covering the Google Cloud Load
Balancer.
But so you see, there
are several metrics
are the built in
into Stackdriver
to allow monitoring.
Now what I have done is
build a custom dashboard
to monitor all my main servers.
So I'm grouping all servers
on a name by prod MIG,
and also all the
ILB-related statistics.
So we can see here
that the one VM
that the Stackdriver
is seeing already
has a spike here on CPU.
It has a high CPU utilization.
So once we go back now to the
console, we can take a look
and see if the status of the MIG
and if it's increasing already.
So doing a reload--
and we can see
here that, not yet,
but the members are
actually being spun up.
So just one thing, the
VMs are being spun up.
Soon they will be ready,
after the cool down period,
after those 15 seconds.
And they will be ready
to receive traffic.
So once they are ready
to receive traffic,
after it's up and running
in those 15 seconds,
the VM is reported as running.
And after those 15 seconds,
they're configurable.
Then we are going to see
the traffic being loaded,
distributed to all the VMs.
And we'll see the VM utilization
for this first one being
reduced, so be distributed.
So it takes a few seconds.
So also, so you guys know, the
MIG is pretty quick to kick in.
However, it takes into
account the last 10 minutes
of VM utilization
to take decisions
to scale up or scale down.
So that's why it takes a
few minutes to actually make
the decision.
But now you guys can see.
So it has increased already to
240%, I believe, to three CPUs.
So if we reload here, we'll
be able to see the CPU
information and utilization.
So the VMs are already
loaded here and available
with the CPU utilization soon.
And now back to the GCP
console, once you refresh,
we are going to see
this utilization growing
to actually 480%,
which would be the six
VMs that I have
configured times 80%
of available CPU utilization.
So here in this demo, I'm
using the CPU as a metric
to provide the auto-scaling.
But you could also use, for
example, custom Stackdriver
metrics to do this auto-scaling.
So Stackdriver supports
custom metrics.
You can build on your own.
You can install
agents on your servers
to monitor the parameters that
are more important for you.
And then scale up.
Based on that, scale
up and scale down.
So now, as you can see here,
we can see all the VMs ready
and utilization of
200% out of 240%,
which are three VMs times 80.
And now we see that the CPU
utilization in the first VM
is reduced because
now the traffic is
being spread across more VMs.
So I'll do some refresh here
to see the updated information.
Now I think in the next one,
all the VMs will be ready.
And we'll see 480% CPU
utilization available
that could be used.
We'll then do a sort of a--
I will do a fast
forward just because it
takes 10 minutes, taking into
account the last 10 minutes
to scale down.
So you guys can see that
after traffic is stabilized,
I stopped generating
traffic here.
Then we'll see the utilization
going down again and then
scaling down the servers
and back to normal life.
And just to show
you here what it
would look like in Stackdriver.
So in Stackdriver, it
takes a few seconds
to get that information
and load in the graph.
So it's starting to
load here and create
a nice graph for you of all the
CPU utilization and the data.
So now the capacity is
480% and reduced to 120%
utilization average.
So one thing that is important,
this CPU utilization that we
configure here is an average.
It's not a total per
CPU, but an average
calculated of all the CPUs.
And now going back to my
dashboard, my Custom dashboard,
so I have all the
use now added here
with the utilization
on a per CPU basis.
So it can be monitored,
and all the data.
And you can also set the
alerts here from Stackdriver.
So now back to the MIG,
we can see all the MIGs,
all the servers were created.
One thing that I would
like to highlight here
is that I am using
a regional MIG.
So as you guys can see, there
are two instances per zone--
two in central B,
two in central 1C.
So we are providing
zone redundancy as well.
So traffic is being
distributed in the same region
across multiple zones.
Now that's the first
forward that I mentioned.
If we go back and check
now on the details,
the auto-scaling is on, but
the number of instances is 1.
And then they'll
scale down over time
at the course of
those 10 minutes.
Its going to decrease
the utilization,
and then scales
down back to 1 VM,
as you guys can see
there in the graph.
Now back to Babi.
BABI SEAL: So what
this means for you?
Remember the global network.
We support resiliency
with live migration.
And we support scale
and performance.
We hope we've shown you some
aspects of the Andromeda
architecture, how it allows
your network services to scale,
to reliable, and
they're really fast.
One more thing, we are just
announcing an alpha support
for 32 gigabit networking.
Of course, you need the
Skylake CPU platform.
But you don't need
custom drivers,
and you need 16 vCPU or higher.
So these are some of our
GCP networking sessions
that I'd like you to
check out upcoming.
And of course, you can check
them out, the encore versions,
on YouTube.
In addition, if you would
like a cloud poster,
a 36 inch by 50 inch, showing
the Google's Global Network,
please sign up, and
then you'll get one free
shipped to you in
the continental US.
[MUSIC PLAYING]